hey a.t this is what is happening right
now everyone is trying to get in
so it's kind of hard right now because
there's so many people but this is what
happens look at the crowd
[Music]
each year we're now getting instructed
by jeremy scott is how we're doing the
show so let's go find out what's going
on
what advice are you gonna give for me
tonight it's gonna be on the red carpet
i don't think i can give you any advice
i think you're a pro i think you could
be giving advice
actually okay i think he's right good
[Music]
turn off your phone that's my party line
hello
oh my sister's here where are you we're
downstairs
walk all the way to the back where the
um screen is
okay we're here with my sister and my
cousin brooke
that's brooke uh i can't even believe
that she had the courage to come out
here with that
stuff in her hair with photographers i
don't care
and it's pretty cold coming out here
it's very funny so i look bad
i like yeah oh my god i have all these
pins in my hair i
at forgot prepare it for me
can i get one right over here please
nikki
ladies hey ep this is what happens at
basketball someone's walking
i'm here backstage at jeremy scott and
paris has been missing for 30 minutes
probably getting into her first look so
let's go find her so you're back i love
this jeremy scott get up
look in here hi
we're wearing heels with tennis shoes
with adidas sneakers rock and adidas
in the house in them thank god exactly
you gotta keep your ladylike posture how
could you not imagine her anything but
like
cotton candy pink i mean she's like
unwrapped the plastic it's like the
christmas present barbie's under the
tree
she's perfect paris nikki hilton we're
here with e.t
jeremy scott joe we're going to find
christina aguilera it's her
here she is hey you look beautiful
pretty in pink
oh my god i know you guys are well
you got some models
yeah i'm excited to be here it's gonna
be a fun night i think
so how do you think of jeremy scott as a
designer i think he's great you know he
he which i love is unafraid of
experimenting and going that extra i
mean look at these shoes
you know right i mean they're crazy and
they have high heels
in the adidas sneakers i mean i've never
seen that before so it's a little genius
so you're going to kill me you've been
asked this a million
and a billion times what you're going a
tour with justin timberlake
oh it's exciting you know that i know my
yes tour i'm thrilled um coming up
june 4th is our first date and um i
thought you loved me what are you
talking about
i'm so jealous i mean
oh jeremy it's june's big night so we're
really excited
and he did um he made one of the amazing
dresses from
my upcoming video fighter so made out of
kind of
mods
[Music]
so so he's amazing and i'm just happy to
be here to support
and the dirty video everyone's talking
about i love it love
this song we shot with him he's the best
so what do you have to say to all those
people who talk whatever
um it did exactly what it it was
supposed to do you know whether
you loved it or you hated it whether you
you know you saw it and there's so many
you know darn things on mtv anyway it
just like got your attention and it it
made me talk you know so
um i i mean it was the funnest video
i've ever done
you know um it was just being free of
your inhibitions and i think it was it
was great you know um
and a little empowering for females just
to be comfortable with your body
comfortable with your sexuality not be
objectified
while standing in the forefront and
commanding what you're doing you know
um overall so i think it was right i
thought it was awesome yeah
[Music]